meantime we're talking new cars people
have been trying to buy a lot of them if
they can find them but there's been a
major shift in the market for new cars
americans are now buying electric
vehicles in record numbers during the
first 10 months of 2021 nearly 380 000
electric vehicles were sold in these
united states that is a 94 jump from
2020. now little reality check electric
vehicles still make up only about 3
percent of the total american car market
but that number is expected to skyrocket
in coming years and their growth is
driving demand for lithium that is the
main ingredient in the car's batteries
right now america has just one lithium
producing mine it's in southern nevada
and it produces less than two percent of
the world's supply
however that is about to change as our
ben tracy shows us he takes us to a
remote part of california near the
border with mexico that some are now
calling lithium valley
calapatria california is not a
glittering part of the golden state this
seems like one of those parts of
california that oftentimes people forget
about it's the forgotten corner of the
country
there's a tremendous amount of lack of
investment state assemblyman eduardo
garcia represents this region of
southern california known as the
imperial valley his district includes
the sultan sea the largest inland body
of water in california it's also an
environmental disaster zone loaded with
pesticides and heavy metals as the lake
dries out clouds of toxic dust are
causing chronic asthma and other
respiratory diseases for the people who
live here
but now the race to power all those
electric vehicles automakers plan to
sell
could unlock a new future for this
forgotten and forsaken valley it's going
to create an opportunity to transform
the economy
underneath the sultan sea is one of the
largest lithium deposits in the world
the lightweight metal that fuels
lithium-ion batteries which make
electric cars run and also power
everything from our cell phones to power
tools lithium demand is now so great
it's earned the nickname white gold
and this part of california is being
dubbed lithium valley the california
energy commission estimates the salton
sea could produce six hundred thousand
tons of it a year that's far more than
current world demand and it could be
worth 7.2 billion dollars this really
could be the future of american energy
production absolutely rod caldwell is
the ceo of controlled thermal resources
the company just built this 180 foot
tall rig on the shore of the sultan sea
the first part of a 500 million dollar
project to extract lithium it is
drilling a well 8 000 feet down where
the lithium is found in superheated salt
water that can reach 700 degrees inside
ancient geothermal reservoirs so this
lithium has always been here but nobody
really cared about it until now we all
knew was here but at the time lithium
was wasn't really a market for it are
you at a point where as much lithium as
you can get you can sell to an automaker
yes so if we could get more drill rigs
like the one in the background going at
once we have customers for sure
general motors is making a multi-million
dollar investment in the salton sea
project to get first dibs on the lithium
as it plans for 30 fully electric
vehicle models by 2025.
right now most lithium comes from
evaporation pods in south america and
mines in australia almost all of it is
processed in china
the biden administration says securing a
domestic supply of lithium is now a
national security issue so we don't have
to rely on other countries for this
vital source of energy given this is an
american resource is this lithium going
to mainly go to american automakers
100
100
100 at this stage
colwell's company plans to build this
geothermal power plant that will provide
a source of clean renewable energy along
with the lithium this process has a lot
less impact on the environment compared
to mining lithium which consumes a lot
of water and leaves potentially toxic
residue behind
just down this dirt road an existing
geothermal plant is switching gears to
focus mainly on lithium production these
things are no joke eric spomer is ceo of
energy source he says when they opened
this plant a decade ago geothermal
energy was the focus and this liquid
lithium solution was simply a byproduct
well lithium was not worth very much 10
years ago so
the economics of lithium have really
changed the game
so you have a lot of opportunity here
yes and it's a big place i mean there's
a lot of opportunity for a lot of us at
the salton riviera there is never let up
in progress
opportunity has been promised in this
desert for decades this unusual city has
a date with destiny the sultan sea was
created in 1905 when springtime flooding
on the colorado river breached a canal
in the 1950s it was briefly a playground
for the wealthy and well-known
but runoff from nearby farms eventually
helped create a toxic stew eclipsing any
hope of a thriving resort destination
the hype is real eduardo garcia says
this time is different there's potential
for thousands of new jobs and a tax base
that could finally help clean up the
environmental mess you sound excited
about this but oftentimes these
companies will just bring in workers
from somewhere else and it does nothing
for the people that live here that's
true we have introduced legislation to
make sure that the workforce comes from
here and he hopes his neighbors will
play a big role in jump starting
america's electric vehicle future
what we'll see is a community that is
far more thriving than what it is right
now for cbs morning's ben tracy in
california's imperial valley
somebody's looking at that right now and
says i see business and job opportunity
there and you know this is in batteries
for our phones batteries for power
drills electric vehicles you can see why
it's a national security issue to have
it here in america a resource that we
can can mine and generate ourselves yeah
and helping out that local economy yeah
huge clearly they need it as well